two out of the four defenders have had
their solo series axed fans didn't have
any warning before Luke Cage and iron
fist were cancelled so why did Netflix
pull the plug on a pair of their Marvel
shows let's go over all the possible
reasons one it seems unlikely that
certain creative differences could ever
be the sole reason why Luke Cage and
iron fist failed to nab third seasons
within a week of each other
The Hollywood Reporter claims that was
part of the issue at least with regards
to Luke Cage considering both canceled
shows have managed to sow those seasons
it seems odd that the showrunners
Netflix and Marvel suddenly hit
back-to-back speed bumps and their
relationships that couldn't be mended
still a boiling creative tensions could
definitely be the straw that broke the
camel's back if there were other issues
already in play speaking of play it's
not a stretch to imagine that the
impending arrival of Disney's streaming
service Disney Play is likely throwing a
huge monkey wrench into the works for
all of Disney and Netflix's joint TV
properties given that Disney players
arriving in 2019 and is set to be the
exclusive host for almost all of
Disney's original content including Star
Wars and Marvel projects it makes sense
that this might be the first move by
Disney to bring its boys home since the
company has already reclaimed the Danny
and Luke perhaps Disney is also gearing
up to take back daredevil Jessica Jones
and Punisher once those properties
outstanding Netflix obligations have run
their course if Disney really is
terminating shows of Netflix in order to
have all its marvel eggs in one basket
the question remains what will Disney
actually do with them the whole point of
the Netflix shows was to be an outlet
for grittier stories within the Marvel
Universe if Disney doesn't want to bring
that kind of edge over to their
family-friendly streaming service could
this be the end of Luke Cage and iron
fists for good at least on the iron fist
side of things
quality control has been a real issue
both seasons 1 & 2 failed to win the
world over critics and fans alike just
killing it behind the show's slow pacing
mishandled protagonists and the scores
of other issues
you're scared No
Luke Cage definitely fared better with
critics but it couldn't escape some of
the wider cross brand complaints either
bloated episodes and the necessary plot
threads weighed down the storyline
proving the perhaps Netflix's and
Marvel's formulaic approach to TV still
needs some work there's a chance the two
companies recognize this and determine
that these shows were sinking ships and
that it was better to pull the plug now
rather than throw more good money at
them after Matt's Luke Jessica and Dany
received their big team of season with
the defenders fans of the Netflix Marvel
verse got excited about Future cross
brand opportunities would we get another
team around with the defenders season
two what the street-level heroes finally
make some sort of appearance in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe these
questions swirled through fans minds
until nothing happened no second season
after defenders ever materialized and
the MCU still hasn't so much as admitted
the existence of the Netflix shows
characters hello you guys this paints a
pretty clear picture of where the
Netflix shows have been heading nowhere
there still no defender season two in
sight and it's not like Matt Murdock and
his crew are going to get a big-screen
spotlights in a marvel movie when you
combine that with everything else it's
no surprise Netflix a marvel so little
consequence in ending half of the b-list
Avengers solo runs Netflix doesn't
release viewership numbers publicly so
there's no way of knowing whether those
figures had a major impact on the
decision to end iron fist and Luke Cage
still between oversaturation and the
bran stagnation there might very well
have been a different viewers ship
across all of Netflix as Marvel shows
eleven seasons worth of television were
produced and released between 2015 and
2018 with four of those seasons debuting
in 2018 alone that's a lot of superhero
shenanigans to stuff down Marvel fans
throats especially when you consider
that most of these seasons contained
copious amounts of padding and filler
maybe people just got tired of watching
Danny punch things
[Music]